Congress lady Yadira
caraveo yesterday was celebrating birth
control this was Tren this was one of
the things trending on Twitter
yesterday thanks birth control and this
woman I've never heard of this this
Congressman but she says by age 50 women
who had Early Access to contraceptives
earned 8% more per hour than those who
did not as a doctor as a woman as a
member of Congress I will always defend
the freedom to choose thanks birth
control
I love this tweet I love it I don't love
contraception I think that's very bad
but I love this tweet
because this is the best argument
they've got and it's a terrible argument
this is the argument for contraception
the argument for contraception is
sacrifice your children so that you can
earn 8% more money making widgets at the
factory that'll be fulfilling you'll
love that that'll lead to a flour ing
life yeah yeah don't have
kids I I understand there are plenty of
conservatives who use contraception and
who think contraception is fine and I'm
just even pull yourself out for one
second and just think about what
contraception means socially Contra even
forget about the personal choice and if
you like it or if you feel that you've
benefited from it just pull yourself out
socially what it means is fewer
babies we in the United States have a
dying population we don't replace
ourselves it's it's
literally a dying country there there
are fewer Americans every single year
which is why we have to replace those
who are not being born with mass
migration so you got a dying country
with a with a dying western civilization
and then what does contraception mean it
means divorcing sex from the purpose of
sex from the natural ends of sex which
is procreation which means what it
means decadent Behavior it means
ignoring consequences it means being
more promiscuous it means what do what
does being more promiscuous mean it
means more broken hearts it means more
Meo movement it means more uh using
human beings just as vessels for our own
pleasure rather than actually giving
fully of ourselves to another person in
holy matrimony through a love that's so
real that it actually creates another
person it means things go wrong if you
criticize the sexual Revolution
if if you are one of the people who says
man this stuff has gone crazy can you
believe what they're teaching kids in
elementary schools
now you got to ask yourself okay did
that pop out of thin air or did that
come from somewhere else well no it
obviously came from somewhere else this
crazy sexual Revolution didn't appear
overnight the agenda probably comes from
the radical LGBT agenda more broadly
which denies the difference between men
and women uh-huh that's right keep going
well and that was enshrined in the
redefinition of marriage which was a a
decision from the Supreme Court yep
totally agree keep going well I guess
the premise that men and women are
exactly the same and IND discernible and
and can substitute for one another I
guess that comes from well feminism uh
yeah it does feminism which says women
and men are pretty much the same and a
woman needs a man like a fish needs a
bicycle that's totally true where else
though where does the sexual Revolution
come from what was the single event that
upended sexual moras and behavior in the
United States
it was the Advent of contraception and
not just the Advent of contraception as
a as a scientific discovery there have
always been technological means some
more effective some less effective for
putting off conceiving that's been true
for all of history we we flatter
ourselves into thinking that we we
invent every Everything Under the Sun
but we don't a lot of these things have
have been long-standing in history albe
it perhaps less effective in the
past the big change was not a
technological discovery of birth control
the big change was the cultural
mainstreaming of it and the
legal uh the legal enshrining of a
license in the Constitution right now go
to jus.com letter y letter T our friends
at genus cell have launched a new
product called genus cell 3 which works
fast on your under eye bags and
puffiness genus cell 3 is smoother more
luxurious and it uses advanced
technology to deliver complex vitamins
and minerals directly to your face for
instant hydration it is like Gatorade
for your skin this new genus cell
technology keeps your skin looking young
and healthy for years to come the genus
cell fall Classics package also includes
a jawline treatment for a more firm neck
and jawline it also includes genus
cell's anti- wrinkle moisturizer and
deep Firming Serum get your skin ready
for the cold and dry weather if you
don't look and feel your absolute best
you will get your money back no
questions asked go to genucell.com nyt
or you can call 800 skin skin 211 for
extra discounts on this amazing fall
package result in 12 hours or less the
immediate effects are included for free
by the way the founder of this company
great Coptic Christian from Egypt who
left there for the American dream so
head on over to Jus cell.com letter y
letter T or call 800 skin SK i n 211 the
the founding fathers didn't think there
was some sacred right to artificial
contraception
right the Supreme Court the liberal
Supreme Court in 1965 just invented that
supposed right out of whole cloth and
they said yeah in the Constitution
somewhere between the first and second
amendments I don't know it's written in
invisible Inc there is a right for
married couples but only married couples
to use
contraception and that was the rule that
was uh Griswald V Connecticut and where
was that right in the Constitution I
don't know no one's ever shown it to me
but that's what the judges said so I
guess there it is seven years later the
judges revisit the issue and they say
hey actually no we got it kind of wrong
um turns out between the second and the
third amendment somewhere in invisible
Inc is a right of unmarried couples to
use condoms and stuff too where is it I
we'll show you our work later but it's
anyway it's in there it's definitely in
there and we should yeah it wasn't we
didn't get it totally right in 65 but 72
yeah artificial contraception then what
happens the very next
year abortion roie Wade is is dis
discovered in the Constitution the the
magical right to kill your kid that was
between the third and the fourth
amendments I guess in invisible Inc but
that's the that's the log iCal
consequence of it if people are having
what they perceive to be totally
consequence-free sex if people believe
that they have the right to an activity
without the natural consequence of that
activity then when the natural
consequence of that activity crops up as
of course it's going to do people have
to invent another supposed right to kill
that thing to do whatever they can do up
to and including murder to deny the
natural consequence of one's
actions so it's not it's not merely a
simple answer of oh you old fuddy
duddies you think there's a problem with
condoms it goes much much deeper it goes
much much deeper than that to an entire
way of viewing the human person and love
and marriage and the relationship
between men and women which is the
fundamental distinction and fundamental
relationship within the human
race and and this woman boils it down to
so that's the that's the conservative
argument of why we ought to be a little
cautious when it comes to contraceptive
methods the liberal argument is yeah but
you can make 8% more at your widget job
that's the that's the best argument I'm
not even mocking this woman that is the
single best argument you can make
for mandating the right to contraception
everywhere in the world is yeah but if
you if you have kids you might not work
as much at the widget Factory this is
secular liberalism this is Mamon worship
this is all that matters is ticking up
GDP and bringing home a slightly larger
paycheck and having dual income and no
kids ah yes in my old age I'll be so
comforted by the extra 8% that I made at
my widget job no I don't think so I
don't think anyone has ever said that
but that's why this kind of secular
liberalism is collapsing and it's why
what what it is giving way to is a
serious conservatism a cultural and a
social conservatism now represented even
in the Speaker of the House of
Representatives we haven't seen that
maybe ever and on the left
it's giving way to a a more radical and
aggressive but in some ways a more
serious form of political activism it
says no life isn't totally about money
it's about and then they come up with
their own cockamamy answers it's about
my identity it's my my racial Essence
it's about my gender fluidity it's about
but what they're talking about are still
things that are essentially immaterial
it's about my loyalty to this group or
to that group
the the shallow materialism of uh
sacrifice your kids to make 8% more in
your widget
paycheck that is not going to speak to
the ultimate longings of the human soul
so then the question is which direction
are we going to go in the radical left
direction that tears the whole country
to the ground or the conservative
Direction which says no we actually have
things that bind us together and we have
responsibilities toward one another and
we shouldn't just use each other as as
uh economic vessels to to to exploit or
as sexual to exploit for our own selfish
interests but as fellow citizens with a
common interest and a common country and
a common good man what a great clip that
was now hey hey hold
up ring that Bell subscribe to the
Michael nolles YouTube channel we'll see
you next time